House Democrats have ended a 26-hour fit
in this cannot stand we will occupy this
floor and in those late hours I got a
little bit trigger-happy on their phone
and these are some of my favorite
subject weeks this is about to get real
hashtag no bill no break hashtags no
more silence the cameras were turned off
but don't worry the revolution may not
be televised but it will be periscope
don't worry we came for Paris plug emoji
phone emojis Samantha deal with comments
on Republicans like deep we're going to
have a drink in a cigar enjoy protest
when Paul Ryan tweeted this to sit in by
how Democrats is nothing more than a
publicity stunt hashtag stops done this
guy claps backs Clinton style delete
your account you guys kept it light I'm
a pillows ready to logged all over your
favorite city palace
you